es para noches frías como estas que
nieva en kiev que se han creado Estos
espacios especiales especialmente en
esas noches en las que no hay
electricidad como sucedió días después
de ese ataque la semana pasada que dejó
no solamente oscura la capital kiev sino
a la gran parte del país desde entonces
se han creado estos centros llamados
centros invisibles donde aquellos que no
tengan electricidad que no tengan
calefacción y que no tenga agua puedan
venir a pasar y a buscar resguardo aquí
les dan lo básico para sobrevivir
durante estas horas de los ataques Aquí
tienen agua caliente Aquí tienen té Aquí
tienen café y aquí está destinado
siempre dos personas están en este
momento esperando esta es una noche en
la cual hay electricidad al menos en
esta parte de la ciudad Así que no hay
personas Pero ellos están esperando que
y se recrudecen los ataques como lo ha
anunciado el presidente
bolodomir selensky esto pueda llegar
pues albergar a muchísimas personas ya
que estamos en un lugar estratégico de
la ciudad es interesante porque es tan
bastante bien equipado aquí no solamente
están pues Estos salones donde pueden
sentarse cargar los celulares sino que
hay un salón especial para recibir a los
niños para cambiarlos para jugar hay
otro donde pueden dormir también hay
baños tanto para hombres como para
mujeres y también pues obviamente es
equipado con calefacción con agua
caliente en el caso que sea necesario Y
es que lo que está esperando No
solamente quiere sino el resto del país
es que estos ataques contra la capacidad
energética aumenten en los próximos días
y semanas porque como anunciado el
presidente bolodomir selensky aquí se
está haciendo es una guerra
la otra la población
abusando del frío que se viene por
delante